so as i said um the heading is extending
2d vectors
and uh we looked at thinking in three
dimensions before
but on tuesday we didn't really think
about vector language just thought about
that coordinate system do you remember
that okay
now we're kind of going to be in
parallel to that
part in the pun but i want us to get
back into formal
vector notation hence what you can see
on the board here
let's see how much you recall three
different ways to represent
a vector in d and i've even given you
the names which you'll
conveniently start with c uh what does
it look like when you describe the
coordinates of something
in two dimensions what do you actually
write
your brackets right and then it's x
comma
y no big deal we've been doing that for
years and years and years component form
and column form we of course only
introduced recently uh if you wanted a
component form
of the position vector that gets you to
x comma y what would you write
x i and i is out let's let's remember
right
i is our what do we call it it's got a
special name right
this guy here it's a vector but it's not
just any vector it's the
it's the unit vector and in particular
we also sometimes call it the basis
vector because it's a unit vector but in
a particular orthogonal direction that
we're interested in right namely in this
case
the x direction x i plus
y j the other one right
that's fine in the y direction and then
lastly uh column form we still use
brackets just like in coordinates but
what do we do differently
yeah i mean it's called column form
right so we pop it in this uh
vertical arrangement here and for
you know uh for funsies we often
actually call these things down the
bottom
we also call them matrices that things
called a matrix
but that's sort of a it's a
terminology thing you don't really have
to worry about but those of you who do
any kind of mathematics at university
when you do that topic called linear
algebra they might stop calling these
column form they'll just say draw a
matrix make it like this etc okay
now we are going to as the title suggest
extend this into 3d vectors and
mercifully
this part is really easy instead of x
comma y you're going to have
we saw this last time right x comma y
comma z and you can sort of
take everything you've seen here and
there's really not much thinking
involved
to say well i think this is what it
would look like if we consider a third
dimension
in addition to the two that we're
familiar with
now just to buy you a little bit of time
to jot this down right
once you've got this coordinate system
this this way of expressing vectors in
three dimensions
everything that you've learned in the
the foundation
of working with 2d vectors stays the
same so arithmetic for example
there are three operations that you can
do
with 2d vectors what were they again
three operations
start with the easy one starts with an a
you
add add vectors together in fact even
even component form is already the
addition of vectors right there's one in
the i direction one in the j direction
one of the k
direction x y and z so this addition
opposite of addition is subtraction
thank you and then the last just
purely like arithmetic that we focused
on was when we took a scalar
and we multiplied right now
you remember how to do addition
subtraction and
scalar multiplication in 2d vectors
it's really straightforward you hardly
even have to think you just separate out
each of the components and you just
address them do the you compute one at a
time right it's like oh i'm just going
to
add all of the i vectors i'll collect
the i terms collect the j terms
now you're going to collect the k terms
right same with scalar multiplication
you get the idea so that's all
exactly the same as it was before we
then took the distance formula to
remember this now going back
to our vector notation if i had some
vector
a how would i talk about the magnitude
of that what would i put around this
i put absolute value signs right
which we've also remembered from complex
numbers it's modulus right
if i square that because pythagoras
talks about the squares of
hypotenuses and sides in the triangle
then what are we going to get for say um
for say that that three-dimensional
vector x
i plus y j plus z k what would the
result be on the right hand side
yeah fantastic i'm just squaring
everything just like
uh pythagoras used to do in two
dimensions
right now what we want to do is focus on
how do we use this thinking how do we
take problems
which we would have thought okay uh i
i know what this looks like in 2d but
what happens when we add this third
dimension into it and what you'll see is
and this is why we call it extending 2d
vectors
what you'll see is often a lot of this
problem just boils down to
taking the three dimensionally out of it
three dimensionality out of it
and just seeing the the 2d components
card in the pun
the 2d parts the problem that we can
then solve in the ways we used to okay
so let's have a look at this calculate
the angle
that this vector where we're calling a
lowercase a
which goes from the origin to a point
capital a
calculate the angle that makes with the
x-axis where
you've got some coordinates for a okay
and we're going to need our calculators
to get to the nearest degree so please
we should always start with any kind of
problem that involves geometry is
a diagram thank you tarun 5 stars now
you might remember before you start
drawing your diagram you might remember
i showed you a
canonical version like a classic version
of
our three-dimensional diagram with z
going up
and x to some you know fashion coming
out at u
and y going to the right now this is the
most common version that you'll see
but in the two examples we're going to
have a look at this morning i just want
you to push on the fact that just like
we did
on the computer right sometimes this
direction is very helpful
perspective is very helpful sometimes
actually looking at it from a different
angle is more useful now this is the one
you'll see most often
but for this particular problem i
actually think it'll be helpful if we
spin this around a little bit and i want
you to think about as i draw it
why this perspective might be a little
more useful
because of the particular coordinates
i've given to you
so i'm going to put z there i'll leave
that one as it normally is
i'm going to put x in that direction and
y in that direction
okay now as we start to put together
this diagram i'm going to sort of
rehearse for you
how we try and measure on there like how
do i represent 2
3 6 right i want you to think about why
i oriented it in this way and how i drew
that conclusion because you're going to
have to make decisions about
i get coordinates which way is the most
helpful to draw my diagram
236 where am i going to put it what's
the first thing you might put
to clearly represent where 236 is going
to be
xiao x equals two x equals two fantastic
let's just go through the components
in order you can see i put x in this
direction so let's go ahead and put
something
and then we'll specify that that's two
okay so there's my two where am i going
gonna go
next i'm gonna go three
in that direction that's where i've
that's my orthogonal direction over
there so
i'm gonna try and do my best parallel
over there three
and then finally i've got an orange here
the j
which in this case is six is of course
going to go straight up
in the z direction right so let's make
sure that's accordingly
that looks about right okay you're happy
with that so we've uh
concatenated put together our x our y
and our j
which means that this is what i'm
suggesting
a is so where is a the vector little a
going to go yeah it's going to go from
our origin
right all the way up to here is that all
right this is what i'm going to mark
in as a has anyone worked out yet why
i've oriented it
in this way why this might be i mean
it's not the only way but why it's
helpful
hmm what do you can paul
yeah very good so as we sort of um pans
got it exactly right i can see the base
of the triangle down here that
is going to be useful to me in fact i
can see all the pieces much more easily
you remember we actually did this
example when we are oriented in the
classic position
what you're looking face on or sort of
diagonal on as it were
is this first octant right the first
octane where everything is positive does
that make sense
so if you put something in the first
octant it's coming directly out towards
you
which makes it actually quite hard to
draw diagrams right
even if it's a fairly long vector right
even if
here we go you have a long object right
if it is coming directly out at you you
don't see
very much of it which makes your diagram
not very useful does that make sense
like you can imagine our 236 effect is
sort of poking straight out
so the actual line you're going to draw
is just not very long so it's hard to
just make constructions on it
yeah okay so there's my little a
vector what am i trying to find the
angle that a
makes with the x-axis here's the x-axis
over here so if i were to draw this
angle in i guess it would be
here right between little a and the
x-axis
but i think i still need a little bit
more information to make clear
where exactly that thing is going in
particular
all angles have to sit on a plane of
some kind
right um for example on your page or on
the wall
so the question for you i'm going to get
you to turn to your friend for a second
and have a think about this and see if
you can represent it
which plane is this angle
sitting on if you're trying to describe
this to someone else because you need to
describe to your own brain
where that angle is because that's going
to decide what constructions we're about
to do and then what calculations we do
which plane is the angle we're about to
calculate
sitting on i'm going to give you 30
seconds turn to the person next to you
how would you describe it verbally where
this thing is gonna go
okay have a think so
i am so glad i gave you some time
to discuss that because i knew you'd
have some different ideas
but i'm just gonna transparently admit
to you i didn't know you'd have that
many different ideas in fact i hardly
ever heard the same answer twice as i
went around
i don't know if you have the same
experiences here's what i'm going to
start off with
because i heard this as people kind of
struggling to articulate what's
happening
but it's immediately problematic um i
heard some people say oh it's in the
z direction or the x direction or the y
direction now i just let me remind you
what the question was right
the question was what plane what plane
is the angle that we're interested in
what's it sitting on right why can't i
just say
it's the x direction or the y direction
or the z direction why aren't
any of those an answer which actually is
meaningful in this context
it's not said again the x direction or
the y direction or the z direction
that's not even a plane in 2d we can say
that's a direction and we know what's
going on right
but for example if i said the z axis
right
there is an infinite number of planes
that go through
the z-axis do you agree right in fact
i'm going to take
a leaf out of my own book right this is
where by the way and i'm so glad some of
you did this but not very many of you
right
get something physical out something
that can exist in three dimensions to
explain what is going on so here
this is one of the planes that sits
or passes through rather the z-axis
right but guess what
so does this one here and so does this
one and so does this one i can rotate
around
through so saying the z direction i need
more information a plane is a
two-dimensional object
so you at least have to provide a second
piece of information
now i then heard people say or maybe
it's zy or maybe it's x y
i'm going to give you a clue here right
it's none
of the coordinate axes paired up
together
because the whole point of being 236 is
that we are now
no longer sitting on just one of them at
any given
point does that make sense one of them
would have to be one of the
coordinates which i probably should have
written for us
one of them would have to have been zero
in order to be sitting on say the x y
plane
which number would have to be zero to be
sitting on the x
y plane which is the flat one z would
have to be zero wouldn't it
think about that because that means i'm
flat on the ground i'm not up and i'm
not down right
so if i was two three zero i'd be on the
x y plane because there's no z to worry
about yeah
if i was 2 0 6
2 0 6 which plane am i on
the numbers i'm providing to you are an
x number and
a z number so i'd be on the i think
i'd be on the x z plane right whichever
numbers are provided to you okay
so it's not any of those that are
orthogonal here's the way i would
explain it
for starters um which axis am i asking
you to measure this angle or rather this
vector
to which axis the x-axis right
so i'm going to use the x-axis as my
point
of reference but like i said there's an
infinite number of planes
that all go through the x-axis do you
agree now what i need to do is
for example if i started from the zx
plane
if i rotate over so i'm sort of leaning
now on my side right well
not quite on my side but oblique right
i'm now heading off in the direction
of a so here's the way that i think we
should draw this
okay colors at the ready if you've got
them right
if i draw
this triangle in here and i need names
for this thing right i'm going to
since i've called that a i'll call this
b over here
this triangle i've just now made o a b
it's at an angle right it's at an angle
but
the triangle itself is right angled do
you agree
do you see why it's right angled this
part here is off at an angle but this is
going to be
orthogonal to the x axis
is that okay so this right angle
triangle here i can work with and that
triangle is sitting on the plane
where i'm going to measure this angle so
now i've kind of got the pieces together
i've already got
one of the lengths in this triangle
namely actually i could have just left
it there that's fine
this is two do you agree so i've got one
of the sides
and a right angle triangle i just need
think about this i'm looking for an
angle
in a right angled triangle what do i
need
what's the quickest laziest way to get
to the angle
that i want right angle triangle
already have one side what else could
give me
the angle
cosine calvin you had to cosine like
straight away why did you say cosine
because you can find on the what is the
length of a easier
very nice okay so did you see and that's
why we sort of i reminded you of this
clue rather
if you worked out the magnitude of this
vector and this is why we did the
distance formula at the end of last
lesson
right if you have the magnitude of that
vector that's the hypotenuse
in this oab triangle are you with me
that's how i'm going to do it
and then this side here is adjacent to
my angle this is the hypotenuse
hence cosine following so far all right
okay question why don't you just do um
can't you just find the length of b
a by pythag be a here okay so
yay all right think about this carefully
ain't it suggesting b a here which is
the hypotenuse of what color should i
use
is it the hypotenuse of this triangle
do you agree with that i think so too
if you have a think about it right this
is going to be two-dimensional
pythagoras i guess this one does require
three-dimensional
pythagoras this is the delightful thing
about having so many in the class
between you and the person sitting next
to you i want one of you
to go this way let's go with calvin's
first suggestion for what it's worth
because i wanted to practice it it's the
one i have in my working okay
and then i want the person who's
alternate in the pair to work out this
one you're not going to be using cosine
if you work out a b are you you're going
to use
you can use tan because it's opposite on
adjacent
make sense if we've done it right we
should end up with the same
angle for a o b
let me give you three or four minutes
off you go
come on you should be there for one of
them i did both let's go
who's got an angle for me
73 did the person next to you also get
73 uh where did my black market go okay
this is by the way our approximation
[Music]
now by the way fun fact thank you anger
for providing this um
suggestion here can you tell can you
tell just like
we've been trying to put you guys uh
doing this interest piece right we've
been kind of trying to put you guys in
the position that mrs lees and i are in
when we're trying to learn
new things outside the syllabus right um
rather than being taught
directly by somebody can you tell which
one of these methods
this particular question was crafted to
go toward
can you tell just by looking at am i
working
it was crafted of course you can do it
the second way there's probably a third
fourth fifth it was crafted for this way
how did you tell how could you tell
oh look the numbers are so nice right
now by the way
in pythagoras theorem we first learned
that if you have a right angle triangle
and you have three numbers that do this
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared thing
we would call those numbers a b and c
does anyone remember what the name
of those three numbers would be it's a
phrase actually
they're called a pythagorean triplet or
a triad or a triple whatever
right now because we're in three
dimensions right you don't get
pythagorean triples anymore because you
don't have
three numbers that go into pythagoras
you have count em one two three
four numbers so fun fact these are
called pythagorean
quadruples and two three six seven is
one of them
um obviously it still works out when you
get a third but it's fine makes sense
okay